what up space fam goals in here from
anime up pro and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest crazy one piece
chapter the yonko are fighting the
supernova and things get
shocking pun intended so make sure to
stay tuned for this one
if you enjoy one piece and want to keep
the reviews coming channel the pirate
king within
and smash that like button with no mercy
if you haven't joined the nakama right
now by hitting that subscribe button and
most importantly hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one-piece
videos
and while you wait for the next intense
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist where i
have videos about the yonko warlord
supernova and much more link to that is
in the description now without further
ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all this
chapter is straightforwardly
called emperors versus the new
generation the hype is real with each
new chapter
we'll be getting more and more into this
fight for the ages
and things will just get crazier and
crazier this chapter for example
definitely had crazier moments than the
last one again
as i mentioned in the last video oda
focused on the rooftop
fight the main attraction for the entire
chapter i have no idea how long
oda will spend on just this fight
without jumping around but i am most
definitely
not complaining the metaphor i mentioned
last chapter about the yonko
representing gods the heavens and even
the overwhelming power of nature
continues strong in this chapter kaido
and big mom
tower over the scene and we're told
ominous clouds gather over wano
kaido uses the move destructive wind and
all the supernova
get to deal with it in their own way law
disappears killer dodges
kid lets his mecha arm get cut off since
you can just reattach it with his power
anyway
zoro's method is definitely my favorite
he just slashes it aside in a stoic way
without much fuss
i love how little energy he needs to
exert compared to some of the others
luffy for his part shows off a bit using
his speed to weave
through the wind slashes and then
unleash his kong rifle
seemingly an upgraded version of kong
gun and i gotta say i love how
straightforward luffy's upgraded move
names are
as someone who used to play a lot of
counter-strike i can't wait to see the
kong
up the point being though luffy's
improved attack
does damage and sends kaido flying
backwards this david vs goliath story is
looking very good right now
as david is punching around goliath kid
comes in for a combo and slams kaido
into the ground it looks cool but i
wonder how useful
such purely physical moves like kids can
hope to be against kaido
luffy's got that advanced hockey going
but kids still need something some
special
angle that we have yet to see obviously
kaido gets up
fine and next law has his turn against
the ankle he's never dissected a dragon
before as he says but he tries to guess
where kaido's heart
is and whips out a gamma knife against
him this has been called law's strongest
technique and it can be used to fatally
wound opponents by destroying their
internal organs in other words it should
render kaido's tough skin meaningless
because the move just passes through it
kaido is not defeated as you'd expect
but still he is hurt
and has to admit that these guys can
counter his durability and thus they are
not the suicidal fools
he took them for these kinds of lines
that acknowledge however hesitantly
that the supernova are more of a threat
than the yonko
thought at first get me so hyped up the
thing is
we don't know for sure what internal
organs law actually hit
and how much damage that will do against
kaido compared to other people but we do
know that kaido's dragon form is
actually a good counter to law's ability
because as mentioned it is much harder
to find the heart of a dragon than it is
to find the heart of a human
killer's up next and i don't mean to
anger any hardcore killer fans but i
think most of us expected the least from
him because he's not a captain and he's
not
zoro he tries to cut kaido's scales and
nothing happens
however to our surprise killer decides
he can get through by slicing kaido
up from the inside he uses sonic's
scythe
an attack that seemingly creates
sound-based blades that travel through a
tough hide
and the attack appears to do real damage
across kaido's
entire body killer being able to hurt a
yonko was not
expected and wow i have to say i look at
killer differently now
however just as things seem to be going
too good to be true
big mom blasts killer with some
lightning the move is named indra who
according to google
is the deity of the heavens lightning
thunderstorms rains river flows and war
the god and nature references continue
and this one is pretty epic
kid is shocked to see what happened to
killer not quite as shocked as killer
obviously but still shocked big mom
is truly terrifying here as we see her
from above laughing and saying
as if she were a vengeful god that there
will be no escape for anyone under the
heavens
kaido has to admit that these supernova
are tougher than expected and as he's
about to gobble up
killer luffy gives him another hit as
luffy is moving through the air
seemingly defenseless kaido prepares a
fire blast what i'm about to mention is
the most hilarious moment in the chapter
zoro asks law for a boost after him
having to follow luffy aka another
captain's orders last time
this time zoro is even giving law orders
and even though law does it and knows
it's the right thing to do he's still
upset because of how it looks and
proclaims he's not a babysitter as he
sends
zorro up there to slice kaido's blast
breath zorro is just so
epic first he commanded law then he cut
kaido's fire after cutting prometheus
previously
and now he goes to seriously attack
kaido a moment we've all been waiting
for
last time he did little damage but we
all knew he'd come back with a better
slice
and this is it with enma odin's old
sword zoro prepares his attack
even kaido is intimidated and saying
nani and big mom
so confident in herself a second ago is
actually freaking out telling kaido to
dodge
the move has a great name it's called
flying dragon blaze
but unfortunately it doesn't land but it
does cleanly slice off a horn
on the giant skull of onigashima but it
didn't even have to hit kaido for this
to be one of the most epic moments ever
two yonko were scared kaido the
unkillable
felt like he had to dodge an attack and
it wasn't even an attack from a captain
zorro continues to impress and i really
can't get enough of his character
now to be fair big mom does single out
the sword saying that's not your average
sword and kaido wonders why odin's aura
is emanating from that same sword so
enma definitely deserves some credit
here as a blade
and one of the reasons i think it will
be the key to beating kaido is because
psychologically the blade and odin's
memory
will lower kaido's defenses as well but
props still have to go to zorro and even
big mom says that kaido really
underestimated him
i do want to know what you guys make of
the whole odin's aura emanating from his
sword thing
is it psychological is zoro giving off
the same energy as odin or is odin's
power and will somehow inside
the sword itself i'd love to hear your
thoughts because i'm not sure how to
interpret this right now
zorro despite doing something super epic
is still
furious he missed and gets zapped by
lightning-like killer
his defense is not as strong as his
offense while for luffy he's unaffected
by the attack
because he is rubber after all so
despite big mom turning the entire
battlefield into a deadly lightning
storm and even calling the attack
heavenly dominion shiva's wrath luffy is
still fine like in the seven deadly sins
luffy is not afraid to stand up and
fight against the so-called gods of this
world
kid mentions that the attack is like a
natural disaster and he gets hit along
with law
big mom is shocked that luffy is fine
and he jumps towards the yonko he gets
hit by blast breath and kaido in turn is
shocked when it looks like fire isn't
effective either against luffy as if
this was a pokemon game
but no luffy says that time he kept
going because of guts
and he uses kong gatling to pummel
kaido mercilessly with countless punches
and that is it for this chapter which
passed by super quick because it was so
action-packed
what an amazing chapter kaido did not
look good here
obviously this happened sometimes and
then the next chapter he may absolutely
wreck everyone you never know but he
definitely wasn't as impressive as you
might expect in this chapter at least
he was punched around by luffy a lot
hurt by
killer hurt by law and had to straight
up dodge an attack from zorro
big mom's lightning was truly impressive
and only
luffy could get up and fight right away
afterwards some notable highlights for
me in this chapter were killer doing
better than expected
obviously zoro's epic moment was my
favorite big mom's god-like power was
crazy
and luffy's ability to keep going and
punch around kaido
so much was notable too clearly as of
right now
zoro seems to have the most destructive
potential against
kaido as i expected he would but that
isn't everything and luffy shined more
in endurance this chapter
being able to take attacks and keep
going for me though luffy and zoro are
still the clear stars of this battle
and we'll see how much more lock killer
and especially kid can do
since kid doesn't even have a real way
to hurt kaido yet
and he talked the most about crushing
him for that reason i feel like we will
see
something epic from kids soon as long as
the upcoming chapters aren't dealing
with solely other parts of the story
also kaido is probably gonna bounce back
in a significant way after this somewhat
embarrassing chapter for him
and by the way there will be a chapter
next week no breaks so
get hyped for that i could totally keep
going on about this chapter but i think
i covered most of the stuff i really
wanted to say
as always let me know what you thought
of this one in the comments and what you
expect to see happening next
if you did enjoy this chapter make sure
to channel your inner pirate king
and kong rifle that like button really
destroy give it a head shot with your
kong up
if you haven't join the nakama right now
by hitting that subscribe button and
most importantly hit that notification
bell
or you will miss future one piece videos
and while you wait for the next
intense and amazing chapter to drop feel
free to check out my growing one piece
playlist where i got videos about the
yonko
warlords supernova and more link to that
is in the description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself and
the most donated champion of the world
alpha sigma and are the one-tier patrons
the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata the world acquire
respect pate hepa dr cortman rythian
emperor taku spidey life tinel big
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
and are pro heroes here patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kazowski joel stanton very gucci
jessica kayla faun ruthu and they aura
alicia actor
bonnie parks hinokami and water the red
haired raven florian joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew crews anthony schreiber
hijinks and mr waffles thank you all so
much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life
and of course thank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime uproar link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
which you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer and whichever way
you choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you